guess you heard this morning i tested
positive recovery
but i've been double vaccinated double
boosted
symptoms are mild and uh and i really
appreciate your increase and your
concerns but i'm doing well i'm getting
a lot of work done going to continue to
get it done and
in the meantime thanks for your concern
and keep the faith it's going to be okay
president biden saying he's doing well
after testing positive for covid bride's
experiencing very mild symptoms with a
runny nose and a dry cough and is taking
antiviral drug called paxlovid he will
isolate for five days but says he's busy
working
you may have just noticed that biden
wasn't matched up in that video and the
white house got called out over that
look in the in the video that you saw
there was a video videographer was there
with him wore an n95 mask had the
appropriate distance the six foot the
six feet distance in the same same
situation as well with the with the
photo
and as you saw in the video he was
outside
the positive covid test comes days after
joe biden's middle east trip to saudi
arabia and yesterday the president was
seen mingling like crazy with a bunch of
people sparking some questions over
whether biden
got infected where we don't know but the
white house is shutting down any
discussion of that
where was he infected i don't think we
know um i certainly don't know if you
have any thoughts on it look i i don't
think that that matters right i think
what matters is we prepared for this
moment how can it not matter where he
got it if that is something that of
course is involved in contact tracing
this administration is taking it very
seriously how can it not matter i think
what i what i what i was trying to say
is what's important now
is that he has mild symptoms
uh is that he is working from from the
residence on behalf of the american
people that's our focus and while we
wish the president a very speedy
recovery the white house says there's
nothing to worry about
you guys saw him yesterday he was in in
massachusetts somerset he spoke for 20
minutes in 93 degree weather it was
incredibly hot he was he was feeling uh
fine you know where most of us were
looking for water and trying not to pass
out the president was delivering
uh remarks
all right so the president greg the last
person in america to catch coveted 19
and we wish him well what went through
your mind when you heard the news this
morning well i think i speak for
all americans
all americans and perhaps the world
president biden please get well soon i
mean really really get well soon okay
don't get sick please because i don't
want the crazy cackler in charge okay i
think she was doing cartwheels to work
but um the thing is he does look fine he
looks fine and we know with this stuff
uh the symptoms are mild in this strain
and remember you know thank god his wife
is a doctor so i think that's important
and i do want to dispel uh that rumor
because people are trying to figure out
how he got it he uh you know when gavin
newsom was at the white house he wasn't
sneezing on every doorknob
so uh but this is a this is a reason why
we got to go younger in 2024 because
this actually is a syria it is a serious
thing even though he's probably going to
be fine but you know we're now going to
have coveted around for a while now we
have three things it used to be cold and
flu season now it's cold flu and covered
it's kind of weird they're going to need
to build another aisle at walgreens but
um you know it this is this is i mean
he's he's
almost 80 right he's got medical
conditions that are fairly serious in
the in in his background so i think you
know you got to you got to look at this
and go like you know maybe it's time
that we look and try to think about
younger people getting in like geraldo
said last week you know he passed the
torch pat you got to pass the torch you
know uh but i hope he didn't get this
from a windshield because that would be
kind of cancer
you get it you get cancer that way yeah
but i'm dead serious he cannot get sick
no we did that cannot happen because
we're not america's been through enough
we can't go through a calmly harris
moment right now by the way did you see
her out today she was like high-fiving
or she was thumbs up today uh you know
he you know she i haven't seen that much
energy out of the woman since she took
over as vice president but look we all
wish him well we all hope that he gets
well but i gotta tell you the one thing
that really sent me to the ceiling was
when karine jean-pierre says oh it
doesn't matter about uh contact tracing
are you kidding last year every time i
went through an airport they had to i
had to sign an affidavit you couldn't
leave without filling out a form and
then they would call you up from new
york state and say are you living alone
do you live with someone and i said it's
none of your business well we have to we
have to find out i said why well in case
you get covert i said i don't have coven
well we may have to contact that person
so they're going back and forth my god
what we all went through every time i
flew through and i was flying every week
and they were like oh contract contact
tracing is the most important thing we
do now with him it doesn't matter who
who to get it from do we know we don't
know if it was the saudis or those
people that he was mingling with up in
massachusetts we're just getting word
from the white house they're saying that
the vice president was a close contact
of the president but she's not changing
her schedule at all jessica
maybe this is just the brave new world
and we should be adapting to it i
understand that it feels inadequate to
have the press secretary say this
doesn't matter that you should have a
better worded response than that but
the answer is this is the new normal and
we do wish the president while he is 79
these are the people who have a hard
time with covid hospitalizations are up
for people in his age category not for
people in our age category the vice
president i did not notice any pep in
her staff but i'm sure she's also very
clear on i just showed her because she's
smiling doesn't imply that she's happy
that maybe she'll be able to grip power
and she laughs at everything you're
right but
we've all been vaccinated we've all been
boosted i had my second booster
i know that i had covid having been
double vaccinated and boosted
and
we're going to have to reassess how
society works if contact tracing is no
longer something that's worthwhile
because when you go to an event now it's
not like you're around five to seven
people you can go to weddings with 250
300 people you travel around the world
you meet with heads of state from
various countries etc then just say
we're going to have to move past contact
tracing as a country this is not going
to serve a purpose anymore and just be
honest about that and that's really what
i want to see from public health
officials you know what covet is you
know who it's affecting we know what the
drugs are we know what the treatments
are
what is the new normal in terms of
procedures to deal with what if he has
long coveted and loses his sense of
smell jessica and can't go
and start sniffing people
well first of all i learned a new word
today greg what is it called rhinorrhea
oh yeah it's a runny nose i learned that
today from the white house physician
it's very interesting to learn that new
medical term um dr johnson has it all
the time
yeah i figured it may be a word for
something else
as well um the cova coordinator today
uh said that the president has a quote
mild illness and that is true and it's
been that way for covid for a very very
long time since the beginning covet has
been mild for the vast majority of
people 98 of people so it's good that
we're not panicking and it's time to
move on i do find it ironic that the
president campaigned on shutting down
the virus and here we are now with him
testing positive also today during the
white house briefing it was absurd to
watch the white house press secretary
and the coveted coordinator
answer questions second hand and not
allow for the white house physician to
answer questions about the health of the
president of the united states directly
and they kept arguing that it wasn't
tele it wasn't telephone that they knew
what was happening they didn't see the
president because they were calling the
president instead of being in the room
with him
that would have never flown under trump
they would be accused of hiding
something uh et cetera so they should
make the white house position available
especially since he's president biden's
personal physician as well and he would
have all the answers to those questions
finally it's interesting to see the
white house and the president today
saying thank you for the vaccines i'm
doubling double vaccinated double
boosted that's why my symptoms are mild
but also continuing to try and take
credit for operation warp speed which is
something that president trump put into
place and by the way let's not forget
that it was president joe biden then
candidate biden and kamala harris who
questioned uh the efficacy of the
vaccines at the beginning that now he is
thanking for uh
you know having him feel better today so
that they weren't gonna say they weren't
gonna take it they yes they did yes they
said that they said they weren't gonna
take it if it's trump so we're happy
that the president is doing well um he's
not at walter reed which is good but you
know i'm getting getting a booster just
so i can see over the dashboard very
good
is that it
yeah do you want to say something else
about other things but then i'm thinking
i don't know do i want to get in trouble
it's thursday i got to fly somewhere i
don't want to have to be checking my
phone so you know i just want to again
reiterate that we hope we pray
that he gets well right for the sake of
the country in the future of this
universe okay how's that we wish you
well joe biden hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now